this has been a big day and an emotional
day
for millions of families up and down the
country as children
see and play with their friends at
school for the first time
in months and although i know that some
will have been anxious as pupils always
are on the first day of term
i also know that the overwhelming
feeling
is one of relief and we all know that
the education of our children is so
important
that the greater risk now is keeping
them out of school
for a day longer i want to thank all the
teachers who've got their schools ready
and have been teaching throughout the
whole period whether that's remotely or
in person
your work has been astonishing
and i want to thank the parents and all
those who've been teaching
at home who've had to master zoom who've
had to communicate every detail of the
syllabus from fronted adverbials
to quadratic equations and we all know
that the
so the burden has disproportionately
fallen on
on women often holding down jobs and
providing child care at the same time
so our job now as as government
is to build on your efforts so that from
now on
our school children not only catch up on
lost
learning but take the biggest possible
step forwards
with a concerted national program for
educational
recovery it's thanks to all of you
parents teachers pupils thanks to this
huge national effort
to keep kids at home that we have been
able significantly
to reduce the spread of the virus and so
today we've been able to take that
crucial first
step on what we hope is our cautious but
irreversible road map to freedom
today allowing people to meet one-on-one
outside for the first time in months
allowing care home visits to take place
with all
appropriate precautions and this first
step on the road map
is made possible above all by our nhs
which has now vaccinated more than
one-third of the entire uk population
we take this step with confidence
because
all four of the most vulnerable groups
have not only been vaccinated in
overwhelming numbers
but it's now three weeks since they've
or at least three weeks
since they've received their first dose
so that they'll be feeling
the full benefits of the vaccine
protection
we will continue on this road map
but we must remember that today's return
to schools will of course have an impact
on the spread of the virus
and so at all times and as we decide
on the next steps forward and when we
take them
we will be driven by the data and with
the number
of patients being admitted to hospital
with kovid
each day still around eight times higher
than the lows of last summer it's more
vital
than ever to follow the rules hands face
space
and please continue to stay at home
protect the nhs
and save lives